Pues yo la verdad que en Cara no me viste el darrefle.
Pues tranquilo,
yo te muestro que es 1
ni 1 recta. Udiusper.
Juan VA a preguntar por la programación cultural
a la rechingada de cultura,
y no VA a ser ni para contestarnos.
Oper, Juan José María VA al metre,
que no sabía que había Fe
ante 1 subvención desde hace €1 000
en estos momentos, eh.
Y ya os voy a enseñar unos,
sí, sí, o sea, no sé dónde está.
No se da 1 stretch. Si saber a algo,
eh, pues te contestaré inmediatamente.
O también para el rechidor de Toty de RES,
Jaime 70 10, voy a contestar los correos,
pero al final di,
pregúntale a este mix,
vuelve bonanit, eh,
a totes y a touch,
y acaben antes los en 70 milabres que nos van, promete,
eh. Bueno, con respecto a los 270 000 árboles,
que no sé si llegaremos o no,
ya hemos plantado 600.
Vamos haciendo camino a ese ritmo,
3 en change fácil,
o sea que lees en pleno
y no hay estima de verdad,
son compromís o fiafertu